i'm 100 a twitter and instagram addict
if i were to pick one
it would be twitter but i'm not kidding
it's a
it's a constant feed it's the end of an
era what happened chrissy teigen
announced on wednesday
that she is saying buh-bye to twitter
and deleting her account
the model-turned-entrepreneur explains
that over the past decade
she has shared so much of her life but
instead of the platform being a place
where she can express her thoughts and
make friends
she says it's become a place full of
negativity
quote this no longer serves me as
positively as it serves me negatively
and i think that's the right time to
call something my life goal is to make
people happy
the pain i feel when i don't is too much
for me i've always been portrayed as the
strong clap back girl
but i'm just not i think twitter is kind
of a snarky fun place i don't believe in
like
inspirational twitter really i think it
should be fun and
light the mom of two adds quote my
desire to be liked and fear of pissing
people off
has made me somebody you didn't sign up
for and a different human than i started
out here as
live well tweeters please know all i
ever
cared about was you but before signing
off chrissy encouraged people to
remember that their words
matter acknowledging that she's made
mistakes over the years
been held accountable for them and
learned an incredible amount on twitter
but one thing she says she hasn't
mastered is how to block out the
negativity
and in true chrissy fashion she closed
it all
up in a sweet yet sassy and hilarious
way
telling her 13.7 million followers quote
i love you guys and i cherish our time
together i truly do
i also hate you oh man
chrissy also addressed her decision on
instagram giving credit to twitter for
helping her deal with the trolls
all these years i'd like to think that
in the past few years i've kind of i've
pulled back definitely on
on what i like to say or what i want to
start
a lot of times there are things that i
want to say but and there's things that
i believe
but i don't necessarily want to deal
with you know the backlash chrissy first
joined twitter in may 2009
and over the years she's been vocal
about all aspects of her life
from the happiest moments to the most
heartbreaking
but don't despair there's still a whole
lot of chrissy to love
on instagram i guess i do spend time in
stinky dirt
you all sleep on the dog filter 38
minutes of fat burning fun
oh and let's not forget tick tock does
anyone just use this like
like a normal thing like just talking
the 35 year old food connoisseur
recently joined the platform
and we are 10 out of 10 here for it
i love it